all right trans people in palm springs
are getting paid for being trans
yeah i saw this that's the word that's
the headline now
is there any checklist you're like you
got a like checkpoint where you got to
be trans enough you got to prove it
somehow or you just say i'm trans and
you get some money that's a good point
because trans isn't operation transits
yeah well you believe despite what you
were assigned at birth
do you have to put on your license at
least
and how much do you get because
apparently they've allocated 200 000
total for this how many trans are there
in palm springs so twelve well there's
nothing like let's be real about this
there might be a lie just i don't know
it's a huge gay community yeah but
that's different dude you understand
they're not the same you
might like each other they yeah hang out
together you know the lgbtq pluses
yeah they hang out together and make
them the same person yeah but if they're
all gonna be in one area we all hang out
together but al still took our money for
black lives matter that's a good point
that's a good ass point actually thank
you but uh no apparently what they're
doing is like they're trying to test out
like this universal basic income concept
where they have they're gonna basically
just like allocate a thousand dollars a
month to different people and they're
like okay well what group should we do
it to and they're like well it seems
like trans people would be a small
enough group that it's not going to like
bankrupt us for the experiment palm
springs and you choose trans
you're going to start with black it's
probably like two yeah
but they basically they're doing it
control groups
they have 20 trans people that they're
doing the experiment with and then
there's 20 trans people that they're not
doing the experiment with they all have
to be below the poverty threshold
and uh they're basically just doing like
a control group that's on like social
security like assisted living than the
other group that's on universal basic
income see what happens in six months
so i'm actually kind of like all right
that's kind of an interesting experiment
you know what i just realized
this is this oh sorry go go i i i know
you go you go no i'm just like really
fascinated by this so what is the idea
like that we're just going to give
everybody using universal basic income
that is just what life is going to be i
think we're getting there as ai takes
more and more jobs i think we're going
to have to go but it's interesting
because the mayor of the town is a trans
woman
and they asked her and they were like yo
what do you think we should do about uh
this program and she was like nah
universal basic income is not the move
we should not go forward with universal
basic income oh so they were trying to
get her
in on it by saying we'll give it to the
trans community first now she looks like
a
like a doofus what it was uh now she
looks like a dummy now she looks like a
dummy not taking care of her people this
is a brilliant political move they want
to push out this universal basic income
thing right they're trying out a small
community they have a trans mayor the
trans mayor has the whole trans
community out there supporting her so
they go we're going to give it to the
trans community first all the people in
the trans community like yo this is lit
a free thousand that's fire i want that
blow the poverty threshold allegedly
according to articles okay what's the
poverty threshold in palm springs 800
thousands yeah probably maybe
but now she's got all this pressure to
do it because it's taking care of her
constituents
but like specifically the community
supporting her so now she's got to say
no to the people that are in her
community especially the poor people
that oh this is smart politics she says
she doesn't believe in uh she doesn't
believe in universal basic income that's
an interesting political move right
there that's that chess [ __ ]
that's that cheshire we gotta get good
at for running for president yeah no
you're right yeah like you gotta learn
how to do this [ __ ] they manipulated
this [ __ ] into doing something she
didn't wanna do by getting all the
people that vote for her
to be into it
game of thrones [ __ ] that's tyrion [ __ ]
you